Richardson is the female track star who
was disqualified from the Olympics a
couple of years ago because she tested
positive for marijuana and many people
including Richardson herself complained
that the rule against marijuana use is
absurd and pointless as marijuana is not
likely to give you an advantage in
competitive Sports
this is probably true I guess but I
always more so wondered why she would
use marijuana when she's in the middle
of qualifying for the Olympics given the
fact that it's a banned substance
marijuana is illegal it may not be
necessary to ban it at the Olympics but
it's even less necessary for Olympians
to use it and if I was hoping to compete
in the Olympics and the Olympics had a
rule outline the consumption of anything
like if they had a rule out along the
consumption of Cheez-Its before
competing and they had a test to
determine who had used Cheez-Its I'd be
severely disappointed I'd be confused I
wouldn't agree with the rule but I still
just wouldn't eat the Cheez-Its as
difficult as it would be to abstain
because it would be more important to me
that I get to follow my dream and
compete but that's just me so she chose
to sacrifice the Olympics so that she
could smoke weed